talk about blue dungeons
[Music]
and today you know what's going on that
thor trailer that came out last night
baby and uh we're gonna be getting into
thor gore and so much more uh with me
to uh dissect our multiple uh gods of
thunder i've got my good friends uh mr
thomas bechtold
that's right thunder in the sheets
thunder in the streets
my thunder is never discreet i'm talking
about farts
um
oh yes he is
we've got oh oh yeah she is we've got
the wonderful jessica clemens here
i don't have any puns as good as tommy
we all know i can't think on the spot
like tommy no nobody can he's he's he's
one of a kind and then uh
not one of the kind we've got the dime a
dozen mr brandon baron
yes a dime a dozen though it should be
noted i was the body model for chris
hemsworth for this film uh he called me
up yeah he's been working out to get to
my level my level i was like that blood
looks familiar
yeah he's like uh he's like you show me
from wrong but it's brand new back door
well and also both because you're a
noted butt model but also you already
had those tattoos right yes i already
have the tattoos you might be saying
what tattoos there's a breakdown coming
to the channel any any minute now wait a
minute
tattoos touched up
new rockstars will be zooming and
enhancing in fact they might have
already done that already depending on
when you're watching this but let's get
right into this thor news oh real quick
we appreciate your chats this is live
though we are shooting this remote you
might be seeing this and being like that
looks like a shirt they probably
pre-taped no we are 100 live right now
uh we have some studio issues so we we
can't shoot in our gorgeous normal
studio we'll be back there on thursday
but for the next couple days we are we
are shooting this remotely from each of
our uh individual domiciles uh but we
appreciate your super chats we'll be
coming back to the chat frequently
throughout the show to hear what you
have to say throw your uh thor trailer
thoughts
in the chat uh when we hit multiples of
a hundred bucks on super chats which is
so kind of generous of of everybody
that's throwing us a few doubloons there
uh it unlocks our swear jar and the
swear jar like a genie's lamp uh when
it's unlocked it releases a swear the
first host that notices this is allowed
to go on a profanity-filled tirade okay
uh we're not supposed to cuss until then
you you be the judge of that
but first and foremost we gotta do the
headlines
brandon
there's a headline dan headline
um well of course off of the thor 11
thunder
second trailer that dropped last night
uh we've got a lot of news related to
that release uh in exchange in the
trailer we've we've been debating this
talking about this all all day an
exchange in the trailer suggests that
jane foster might have been blipped
right we've been debating this back and
forth and actually i think brandon has
the definitive answer uh when thor is
like or jane says was it been like three
or four years and thor responds eight
years seven months in six days give or
take uh
now some people in debating the
difference between those two numbers is
roughly five years
could that mean that she was blipped for
five years brandon you've done some
research on this
yeah i thought i remembered her being
blipped and i thought that was like well
known i went back i looked at
the scene and end game when they're kind
of when tony's back from space and
they're all kind of debriefing and
checking notes and they're showing a
bunch of face on the screen they show
eric selvig they don't show jane foster
but then in the script for end game the
shooting script for and game it's
there's a bunch of names that are listed
that you show you are supposed to see
who was flipped and she's listed there
now the script had also listed wong
initially and then that was like later
revealed that oh wong didn't blippi
became the source of supreme very
important we know
if you remember that when they made
those character posters the ones that
like were in black and white were the
people who had been blipped the ones
were in color were people who hadn't
wong was one of the color ones that
hadn't been blipped but the script had
said he was so we we didn't always know
for sure if j it was always assumed that
jane was it seems i found a bunch of
articles from like 2020 saying she had
been blipped but now we i think this
pretty much says she was black for sure
for real confidence blip confirmed maybe
they would have made that
uh even more obvious if they knew for
sure she'd be coming back to film
another mcu man yeah i think they were
waiting to see like do we just keep it
blipped forever i don't know
um the trailer also revealed or hinted
at a ton of different cosmic entities
right we knew there were going to be a
lot of gods in this movie but like
cosmic entities like the living tribunal
death uh
and we're actually gonna be coming back
to that later in this show with our
break room breakdown that jessica's
gonna lead us on so put a pin in that if
you're if you're chatting about those we
we know those we we're going to talk
about that a little bit um we also got
our first full look from the front
speaking of full frontal of russell
crowe zeus
and uh you know as promised by taika ytt
this is a performance from crow that we
haven't seen before full bushy beard
yeah greek accent
what how would you define that accent
tommy
to me it sounded like a greek man trying
to come let me sell you italian pizza
pie on hollywood boulevard
would you like a
a a pizza with olives and uh and onions
for seven dollars it costs five cents to
make we also sell euros uh we also sell
uh south salisbury steaks like deep cuts
for those yeah
[Laughter]
[Music]
we only got a few words from him but it
was a jarring accent neither his native
australian nor the kind of like
american-ish accent he adopts for most
of his film work yeah it was very
interesting
um and immediately after the trailer
dropped we got a brand new poster
released to the official twitter page of
the movie john do we have that asset we
can roll
oh nice very nice
and in an interview with total film
director taika ytd said fans assume it's
the passing on of the torch
i don't think that's the case
interesting
yes well hemsworth has been one of the
few
original avengers that is like i will
keep doing these movies i do not want to
stop playing thor i mean if you remember
when they originally
released like the salaries of those guys
it was like robert downey jr insane
salary i think ruffalo or ruffalo as
hulk was getting a decent amount of
money because of his career hemsworth
got like 250 000
something like that so i'm sure now that
he's commanding
seven figures and then some he's like
and also i'm sure he legitimately enjoys
the roles and i i mean they have to be a
blast to make those movies that's a
really fun cast of people that are not
really known to be like [ __ ] in real
life or sorry jerks in real life so
apologies sorry sorry that was on a slip
of the tongue uh
but uh
i yeah i hope uh i i i hope hemsworth
yes i hope they do a thor five thor
stick i hope hemsworth is the real life
jason he's like
when he seems to really have found a
collaborator that he jives with with
taekwondo right those two both seem to
have a great time both making these
movies and like kind of consent you know
filming them as well yeah
right
now i have a question sorry not to dip
into the headlights myself as you know
my my high-tech computer can't see the
script but i did have a hand in
constructing it today
and i don't think i put this in do you
guys think that korg
narrating the trailer was a device for
just the trailer or do you guys think
that he's going to be the narrator of
the film because it felt conveniently
con conjuncted for like for a trial
and i think that like i think he is
gonna be the narrator for the film but i
don't think he's gonna narrate the
entire film i think it's the beginning
and then it closes at the end kinda
imagine if you will um
i can't remember the play uh it's on hbo
max now but i think it's gonna start
in the heights yes it's gonna be in the
beginning and at the end
um also because i i guess i have
theories to how gore the god butcher
will play into this so we can talk about
that later but that oh i mean i will say
corga's voice by taika watiti who
directed the film who probably like
helped cut the trailer maybe and it
might he might have just been in the
booth had been like i'll just make it
seem like
narrating this and it's not going to be
in the film at all
i wouldn't doubt i bet that scene we see
him open the trailer where he's like
talking to some little blue kids or
whatever that is probably certainly in
the movie but
he that's the only time he's on screen
actively narrating so all the narration
after that yeah could have been vo his
whole like spoke too soon line jake
foster shows up yeah i definitely could
have been just for the trailer why not
yeah wow
but i i and i agree with jess that it
will probably be a fun framing device in
that way where we we open with it and we
come back to it especially guys i mean
that's how rapidly
i was like that's how ortho ragnarok
opened with him narrating himself being
trapped yeah
yeah oh you could also see it
a lot is gonna happen to thor like you
you get a sense of like his whole like
journey of self you know having his uh
jeans and and and cut off sleeves and
like trying to hang out with the
guardian stuff like that that all might
be in the first 15 minutes of the movie
you know and like the the narration
might kind of help fuel that as like a
montage before we get into the the jane
and the gore um
lines yeah yeah i love his like gold
mask ridiculous gold mask helmet thing
yeah dude which is so crazy i love the
gold i feel like that's like the odin
inspiration right you know i don't think
donald trump is taking over for odin
she's obviously like the king of asgard
but like i think he's getting some of
that like all father magic
imbued into like his armor and his like
new helmet and stuff it was so
ridiculous i loved it
high on the ridiculous scale uh shifting
away for a minute we're coming back
we've got a lot to talk about with that
thor trailer but in some dc news
james gunn tweeted out a cryptic photo
of bloodsport
potentially indicating that the
character would be returning uh
to the dceu either in the upcoming
amanda waller tv show planned for hbo
max or the planned suicide squad sequel
when asked if the photo confirmed
bloodsport's return gum gun simply
replied that would be nice wouldn't it i
mean there's even potentially could come
back for peacemaker season two right
yeah right sure
yeah i i uh i love like james gunn being
like i don't know i tweeted that out so
does that mean he's coming back i can't
i can't stand james gunn's tweets uh hot
take hot take i'm so done with them i
and i didn't recognize it until we
started doing this dang show that i
started recognizing
how many like how many times we have to
talk about him tweeting him because he
always yeah he just doesn't like from
his toilet he literally is just like i'm
gonna play with this nerd a little bit
and i'm like
and i ironic that you've taken a stance
against james gunn's current tweets
which is you know i think pretty a
pretty hot take as you said most people
look at james's older work with the more
schools
as somebody who's had twitter bite him
in the butt at least once you would
think he'd maybe like reconsider some of
his social media presence but not maybe
not it's also worked out well for him in
other instances so wasn't there supposed
to be like a stand-alone film for the
will smith dead shot character that's
who bloodsport essentially replaces so
maybe they just kind of they could be
shifting those resources over if it's
still in the budget i don't know well
there's just will smith erasure all over
hollywood now they're like the rock will
be g they're like
like pretty soon like they're gonna do
bad boys with martin lawrence and like
this particular will smith erasure
happened way before the slap right yeah
yes absolutely and it might be due to
his his rate as a
huge movie star kind of dictating the
terms of his film appearances whereas
maybe you could get idris elba for you
know a bargain compared to mr smith um
uh oh the last of us director now i
can't pronounce this this person's name
very well kantamir balagov apologies uh
gave an interview to comicbook.com where
he acknowledged that the show is still
in production
and will probably release early 2023
i haven't heard of anything about it for
a little bit sick
awesome can't wait
and that's we that is starring uh pedro
pascal
yeah i think that's yeah is that an hbo
yeah hp
well it was i mean it was an hbo show
when they first announced it but i know
sometimes they move around but i believe
yes that is an hbo we might be covering
that here on the channel when it comes
out we'll see we'll see what the
appetite is for it stuff like this has
the potential to blow up and have a huge
place in the zeitgeist or maybe just
have this little niche cult following
hopefully as we here at new rockstars
through content like the break room are
able to expand the kind of content we
make and the kind of things we cover
hopefully something like uh the last of
us we can we can cover and if you're a
big fan and you're looking forward to
that show
um
tweet new rockstars
in our break room we want the last of us
give us the last of us
yeah because we're gonna talk about it
in our in our break room so we might as
well talk about it ah
it's true it's true um and then finally
uh the thing we've got to talk about
probably what's yes what is that because
you're corny
you made a porn your touch of it is
corny your judgment is corny and me and
the internet are sick of it hashtag
hashtag tommy too corny
got me two chords
anyone please hashtag tommy
they're auto blocked
you want to see my right hand move
faster than it did when i was 14 years
old tweeting tommy is that is that the
number two or the t-o-o i just needs it
now yeah it's like scotty it's like
also started trending when people were
sending you feed pics right
some of those feet were a little corny
you guys need better shoes you guys need
better shoes
how dare we go down this rabbit hole but
um
we got to come back too this was
probably i think this was the thumbnail
of this video um we got our first look
at christian bailey score the god
butcher
in
i don't know if we had predicted
accurately or at least i personally was
like oh he'll probably have like a cgi
face or something like that was anybody
here thinking it was basically gonna
look like
christian bale with with some heavy
makeup
i don't think anyone was expecting
straight face and let me say i was
[ __ ] shocked when i saw it that's
right check the document check the
document wow
we hit 100 bucks on the swear jar thus
unlocking uh brandon's if you save
f-bomb thank you to owen john chrissy
martin i loved all the other folks john
ayton who helped us get there see the
people saying that this is pre-recorded
again in the chat we i see your guys
don't acknowledge them don't acknowledge
the haters we will we'll get to you
we'll get we're we're real we're real
but i was really shocked you have this
beautiful
bold colored film going on and this guy
walks in like he's doing a
a college production of macbeth or
something like that like so dramatic and
yeah just a very normal face i'm glad
they didn't do the weird nose it would
have been too voldemorty i think we've
already had that like i love just seeing
the bail the full bail baby
put it out yeah give me the full bale
the full hay bale well people have
talked about like if you were gonna do a
full cgi like do you then need to
hire such an iconic actor is christian
you know what i mean if
like we all know that face we've seen
the bottom half of that face and some of
the best uh superhero movies of all time
right like um to not then show us that
face would would in and his ability to
act through his facial expression feels
like we would lose something there this
is the antithesis of malikith right like
this is doing the exact opposite like
not putting too much makeup on the actor
and letting him just perform and be
awesome
i i really like what they did with the
club
when they first said i apologize if you
hear loud banging noises my neighbors
just got married no uh they're taking
the uh thomas they're taking the dump
they're they're they do the dumpster
removal on tuesdays they just got
married right is that what they call it
doing the old jobs
yeah they're doing the dumpster removal
uh no i i remember when they first
announced the casting of christian bell
in in this movie and there had already
been we already knew that the guardians
were going to be in the movie and there
was a bunch of and i was like i'm so
sure this is going to be a cgi voice
performance because when that it seems
like a lot of times when you get someone
like like when bradley cooper did
guardians of the galaxy you're like yeah
because he you know i mean he did a
great job it does a great job as rockets
voice but it's not as as uh painstaking
as going to the set every game didn't an
ex james gun say that him had been
diesel have like never been on set even
because they don't need to oh
i just kept imagining that he was gonna
look like ronin uh yeah and i of got
that yeah so i think i'm fine i'm
content with i just assumed they would
like try to make him look like roman
i'm i'm just happy that we're getting a
physical
uh christian bell performance you can
see him too a little i love that you can
see and hear him still and you're like
this is just christian bale mad at the
gods
yeah it's not not as much acting as as
you might think um well i also say you
definitely get the sense even though we
got some good looks at him in this
trailer and we're going to talk about
some more specific parts of the the gore
um presentation that we got there but
like we have only seen the tip of the
iceberg we haven't seen this guy fight
that much we haven't seen him move we
don't know what kind of power this uh
weapon he has is and so that that's our
transition here we see this beautiful
shot of him grabbing the hilt of this
sword
probably confirming that's the necro
sword
i believe that's what it's it's supposed
to be i unless they're gonna show us
another one at some point i don't know
but we can assume that's the necro sword
it looks pretty
black necro-y pretty necro pretty dark
pretty evil
and they're making a point right like
giving that its own shot its own kind of
long shot in the trailer right to draw
attention to it this is an important
part of this character yeah
i really didn't
oh i was just gonna say can you tell us
a little bit about the necklace yeah the
necro sword was created by no who was
like the progenator of all of the dark
symbiotes you know he's the evil dark
elder god and he made the necro sword
which was like the very first symbiote
and
uh he and supposedly the necro sword was
used to cut off the head of the
celestial uh in the past and like a lot
of people have theorized the mcu nowhere
you know the floating head of a dead
celestial that could have been the
result of the necro sword being used uh
on on that celestial and it it does tie
in with like you know venom and all that
symbiote stuff and we know that a little
bit of the venom symbiote was left
behind in this universe uh so that's
very interesting you know i that scene
when he's kind of going through all
those weird black tentacle looking
things it's very symbiote-esque
i think that would be it would be really
cool to tie all that together in this
universe
i definitely got cutting off the head of
nowhere's vibes when he he plunged that
sword into whatever that was was it like
the head of a giant
creature looks like a plane
or maybe i don't know and i don't know
if that's the sword doing it if there's
something else involved i don't know
uh i guess we'll wait see it almost
looks like that could be where they were
fighting later because that planet was
also gray
and grayed out i talked about the one
the part with him in valkyrie
yeah
well no there's a shot just of gore like
plunging like directly into
down right
um
though let's transition to talking we
get a great look and this circles back
to yesterday's mandatory fun not to
belabor it but we did a little betting
on our predictions for the trailer i
can't wait to hear and i want to shout
out he's not here right now he's back to
being off screen
but on-screen producer john
had the most accurate prediction i
believe right
in that
he predicted that we were gonna see like
the moment maybe right before a beloved
character dies
now
we all got our fingers crossed for
valkyrie
but that is not her demise that that
fight scene we see but
not looking good
for her she's going one-on-one with gore
in that way so is that was that john
john bet that valkyrie would die
he he he offered it up in a few years
that's right i spotted eight to one john
benton that valkyrie's gonna take her
last breaths coming in it i actually
might have been twelve to one i'm not
sure what the odds were you gotta deal
more it was eight to one the valkyrie
was gonna die in a fight and i'm not
gonna lie to you after looking at the
tapes it looks like that most likely
happened more on this in the mandatory
fun segment
um and in like what a cool contrast i
guess this also segues with as brandon
mentioned every time we see gore in this
um
trailer it's it's this grayscale kind of
like the colors are muted almost like as
if he has that presence about him like
he kind of turns things black and white
anytime he's in in the space and that's
such a contrast with it looks like we've
been speculating is valkyrie swinging
like one of
um zeus's lightning bolts in there
yeah that's what it looks like there for
sure
yeah so there's this huge contrast in
color and vibrancy in their fight now
real quick what do we think is the
outcome of that battle
i mean
i would hate to lose valkyrie
if
i think some big character has to die to
really give gore some stakes right some
some heavy stakes
i think the outcome of that battle is
tessa thompson is available for crete
westworld season five
and any other projects that you may want
to hire her for beyond the role wow
i think that
it's a battle scene between more than
just
those two i think those are the only two
that we saw in the shot i i'm still
thinking it's gonna be jane foster
that's going to die i guess like
not only for the backstory but because
in like uh thor
god of thunder the issues thor basically
uh
like cuts off the okay so okay so
basically thor god of thunder the issues
uh like
one through like 14. thor and gore the
god which are going at it thor cuts off
his hand he comes back and he's like you
know what i'm gonna get a hold of the
time keeper or the time whatever and i'm
gonna destroy
all of the people before they're like
even born when they're babies and thor
is like no and he gets help from all the
other different versions of himself that
could be jane foster and all of those
ones die to gore except for thor thor
encompasses the bomb itself and becomes
like a little symbiote demon man and i
think
not a symbiote demon man but i think
that essentially will happen is jane's
gonna die thor is gonna try his hardest
to like redeem everything and then kill
gore in that way but is is is thor the
mcu franchise that kills the most
main like like top level characters i
mean both his parents are gone brother
gone
uh
the uh carl urban's character gone all
of his friends gone heimdall that whole
game
loki died during infinity war so i don't
know if we'll count that as a thor death
they die in infinity war okay um
also loki as portrayed by tom hiddleston
he died several times in many thor films
though yeah
yeah that's good true tommy there's no
there's no pepper potts uh happy hogan
death scenes that we've had
you know we we lost like i'm trying to
think in like i guess
peggy carter dies of old age
captain america
i mean like
yeah i think you think you're right
tommy thor really has like lost the most
it's something we talked about on i
talked about a big question with with uh
uh mt once was just like yeah thor
really doesn't have anything he's lost
so much of what
is part of the prophecy of like ragnarok
and asgard and the cycle right and the
whole thing with like asgard is it
resets constantly uh and all the all the
asgardians are born again and odin's
born again and thor is born again and
it's like a cycle and the fact that
ragnarok has happened odin is dead loki
is dead asgard is dead i mean asgard is
people not it's not a place but yeah uh
it's almost like thor's just hanging
around and like doesn't want to reset
the cycle
um and i think that would be an
interesting thing if thor did die and
the next door is the rebirth of thor or
something like that well that's what i'm
holding on to i think thor is gonna when
he gets that symbiote it's gonna make
him like doctor strange right now or
doctor strange is still like not bad but
he is bad i mean wouldn't that be the
irony if they bring in the dark avengers
but it's not all these people pretending
to be the avengers it's all our former
avengers who have turned avengers like
that would be a while back
oh i would the dark avengers are coming
from inside the house
that's that's the scarlet witch that's a
dark doctor strange that's a dark thor
like that's a that's a tough team i mean
bucky bucky's got
um wow well
happy hogan's lost everyone maybe he
throws an iron man suit on or or a
punisher logo um speaking of eating it
up with a spoon we want to thank our
sponsors uh that helped us bring this
episode of break room to you
specifically our friends at athletic
greens um we thank you them so much
tommy actually earlier we had a planning
meeting earlier oh and that that
container used to have a g1 in it the
signature athletic greens product but he
downed it you were you were housing that
thing
slammed it housed it and
because i got this very nice bottle from
athletic greens i've been pumping water
into my system all day i'm well hydrated
i feel luscious your skin looks great
i'll be honest guys we're all going to
go see a movie later i don't mind if you
stroke like
when you don't tease me
stroke my face in the valley and tell me
it's real what if we stroke faces by the
battery okay all right well uh this this
athletic greens ad reed has gone off the
rails already but oh sorry athletically
but i gotta say uh tommy's truly
enjoying the athletic greens we we've
all tried and do enjoy it hopefully when
we get back in studio we can even uh be
trying it some more in every scoop of
ag-1 you get 75 high-quality vitamins
minerals probiotics and other great
stuff that makes your face
strokable uh the special blend of
ingredients supports your gut health
your nervous system your immune system
energy focus all that great stuff and uh
you know for us a new rock stars look at
that tommy's a a real a real perrin
kitty today um
we mentioned yesterday it's a big deal
because like we're running around you
know we got to scramble and figure out
how to do this show remotely we've got
to scramble and figure out we're going
to a top gun maverick screening tonight
very excited
and in between all this running around
and making this content sometimes it's
hard to get the kind of nutrition and
the nutrients you need athletic greens
makes that easy because in one scoop you
get kind of everything taken care of all
that and it's affordable
but for cheaper than a coffee shop
coffee you can kind of take care of all
your nutritional needs for the day
like buying yourself some nutritional
insurance uh and right now it's time to
reclaim your health and arm your immune
system with convenient daily nutrition
just one scoop in a cup of water every
day that's it no need for a million
different pills and supplements to look
out for your health to make it easy
athletic greens is going to give you a
free one year supply of immune
supporting vitamin d and five free
travel packs with your first purchase
all you have to do is visit
athleticgreens.com
break room or you can click the link in
this video's description again that's
athleticgreens.com
break room to take ownership over your
health and pick up the ultimate daily
nutritional insurance thank you to our
friends at athletic greens ah
now tommy um
you teased it earlier
is it that time
yeah
uh what time would that be exactly uh i
mean i would say mf in time but it's a
different it's a different kind of mf
it's time for mandatory fun
yes the segment's so nice we play the
graphic twice hit it again
i miss this
oh you know what today we're only
playing the graphics oh i'm just kidding
we're doing it thrice hit it again
now
as we all know
yesterday we took bets on uh the thor
loving thunder trailer and for the most
part the house cleaned up i'm not gonna
lie look you're gonna see a picasso
behind me once i get a hold of zach and
brandon's cash everybody cashed out a
little safety bet on gore the god
butcher showing up but one person really
cashed in their bet brandon also hit i
believe a part of this as well as part
as part of his kill parlay we got gore
the god butcher sword fighting against
valkyrie and what i think was confirmed
this moment right before her death you
will both be receiving a check from the
411 thunder casino uh sometime in the
next 60 to 90 days now
today
is a new day
hey tommy
hey tommy before i hit the graphic again
first of all there's a 99 chance no one
can hear me uh i didn't get paid i never
got paid oh john never got paid yeah
producer john is claiming he didn't
receive his funds
wow you did not i got nothing okay well
uh
yeah like i said the checks will be
coming out but i guess if you want
you could pick mandatory fun today i
think that's a fair i think that's a
fair trade i i do love cash but what i
love more than cash is mandatory fun and
i think i have a great idea
um okay since we didn't get brandon's
wish of a meatloaf song we got another
rendition of sweet child of mine no
complaints but you know it'd be nice to
have something a little bit more fresh
um
here's what i want
uh i want you guys to
pitch me or or give me your 80s power
ballad song so that we have a little bit
of variety i want a power ballad uh for
a specific character in thor love and
thunder that's what i want to hear
all right all right all right okay okay
so we're doing 80s power ballads
to characters in thor love and thunder
and that is john's payment
for mandatory fun yesterday he'll be
receiving no further compensation
all sales are final
uh i think i can handle that you guys
think you can handle it i think i think
i could handle that now um i think i
think i can handle it tommy and i
request to go first only because as the
person with the
worst voice
the least musical training and
experience uh but a thriving love for
80s power ballads um i'm gonna i'm gonna
take a crack at this knowing that
yourself brandon and jessica are all
gonna knock it out of the park okay so
i'm picking i'm picking a specific
character so this this character is it's
from their point of view or or at least
it's we're looking at this character
while we listen to this song and i'm
just i'm not gonna sing the whole song
just a brief snippet so it's like
um
take a cork
set him up
let him speak
listen up
cork tells a story one time
in the name of love of thunder coldtail
it's a story one time
talking jane foster corn tells a story
one time
gotta set it up
nice i like it i like it well i also
feel not great about mine so i will go
second uh mine's uh you know sing-along
if you know the song
uh
it's a steve wynwood banger
from the
1980s
sorry i'm not ready
so wild
standing there
with a sword in her hand
i can't
help remember
just where she swung at me
valkyrie
call me valkyrie
call me valkyrie
i remember you from thor
that was beautiful so beautiful deeper
cut a little bit of a deeper cut i like
it
both of yours
were so good
so good but i think mine's a little bit
better
are you ready um should i tell you what
i think the song
i chose is should we guess
i think you'll be able to guess i think
you'll be able to guess this is the
perfect 80s song perfect 80s song some
would say the number one song of the 80s
i i don't know if i'd say that but i
probably would and i'm gonna sing in the
style of gore the god butcher not in the
style sorry i'm going to sing as before
gore the god butcher you ready
i've been kicked out and denounced
religion crawling through the sand
a couple days later the golden god
starts reaching for my hand
from preparing i need a god to take a
chance on a withered with an alien so
give me a symbiote
oh i wanna kill everybody
only if they're a god to somebody
yeah i wanna kill everybody
but they've got to be godly one more
time oh
i want to kill everybody else
[Music]
[Applause]
playback play back one more time
tom petty and technically this song is
early 90s but it's close to the 80s it's
closely 80s uh and i will be singing
from the perspective uh of thor uh who
hangs dong who hangs dong in this film
guys um here we go there's a tom petty
joint
[Music]
i met her in a new mexican town had a
backtalking intern i always was around
when i met her it was love at first
sight we broke it off later but that was
all right
back and she's looking real mean she's
got way more muscles than i'd ever seen
now she's using my shoes using my hammer
and stealing my thunder but wait till
you see my thunder from down under
oh
from don under
yeah last dance with my girlfriend jane
got a god title to reclaim
i am jealous and that's a sin i wanna be
your god
[Music]
you know
folks come here for the insight into
nerdy film and tv shows and trailers but
they stay
for the perfect song uh parody oh my god
first of all i am absolutely dazzled
with all all of your performances
john i don't know if you could have
imagined that what you wanted john in
that that what you wanted john
10 out of 10 he says all right well
we're going to send this off to the
record executives and make a little bit
of an album maybe it'll be on spotify
who knows
there's a poll going in the chat right
now to see who had the best power
balance yeah the poll will just run away
with it maybe the winner yes
well i i understand that
all right guys i got to put the
mandatory fun goblins to sleep with
their special song so hang on a second
and once again the band story fun
goblins are all space
yes okay since you won the song contest
you get to pick tomorrow's mandatory fun
you do since i won't be here thursday
and friday i get to participate in it
because i have a feeling jessica's
mandatory fun will be mandatory
uh unmissable
that's what i'm going to call it
i like that name all right and speaking
of uh jessica leading something uh
you're gonna talk to us a little bit
about that
what a transition baby
we're going into the break room
breakdown play by graphics play my graph
i don't know how long it is
the graphic is seven hours long today on
the break room uh or today on the break
uh the breakdown the break room
breakdown yeah
is tongue twister is boss's new video
breakdown for thor love and thunder the
trailer where there's a specific scene
where it's natalie portman getting her
powers through mulanier but in a room
of ancient statues and we're gonna talk
about those asian statues let's play the
clip first though it is filled with
these golden statues that should look
familiar to you these are all marvel
cosmic entities the clearest one to the
far right is the living tribunal but
he's not alone because right behind a
living tribunal is a bald statue that
looks like the watcher uatu the
character voiced by jeffrey wright and
what if but then if you slide to the
left there is a hooded figure a skull
presumably lady death who in the comics
thanos did all of his dirty stuff for
then on the left in the far back there
is a bald feminine figure who looks a
lot like infinity the sister to eternity
and then between them i think that might
be eon aka he who waits an offspring of
eternity who's associated with the
concept of time so what is this place
i'm wondering if this could be a shrine
into the higher tier of cosmic beings
above the god tier perhaps an mcu
version of those who sit above in shadow
the gods to the gods who oversee the
asgardians and lend mjolnir its power
perhaps it was these figures who
selected jane to wield mjolnir
okay all right guys top of the first
cubs leave the reds one nothing
padding is suzuki pitching is malay the
show is freaking live all right
sacrifice fly
they just scored a run okay show us live
shut your house
okay
he's not coming back i love that that's
how you keep live i'm proud of you tommy
thank you um so yeah vaz's little
breakdown of everybody that's in that
room do we think those gods would have
anything to do with the powers for
i mean all this all this living tribunal
stuff lately is so
it's gotta mean something right like
can i can i can i
relinquish my geek powers for a moment
return them to my fortress of solitude
can someone explain the living tribunal
to me that knows a little more because i
am
greatly under-informed as to who that
character is you want to do it brandon
well i'll say what i know i don't i i i
i know everything cosmic marvel stuff is
some heavy dense stuff that really
warped my brain as a kid uh but you know
he who are the living tribunal kind of
judges
sits above like a lot of the celestial
style entities of the mcu
exists in a place of judgment and like
was involved in
it
the infinity saga in the comic books
they actually go before the living
tribunal to see if like what thanos did
was cool in their living room was like
yeah that was cool that was within the
bounds of the laws of the universe to
them
so they kind of make these weird
judgments from this like higher plane
place and they kind of sit below
like the one above all who would be stan
lee or kevin feige in the mcu they're
kind of this just like
the comics always needed someone to play
referee and if you're if you're already
on a cosmic level dealing with like
celestials and galactus you need like a
referee for that so he watches who
watches who watches who watches you know
who watches who watches who watches and
does nothing to help nothing to help
which is probably why gore wants to
murder all of us uh murder all of them
the gods uh which makes sense wait so
we're he's saying he thinks that these
are the living tribunal is made up of
the
i
watcher
know i think he's saying that like this
room has all these statues to them i
don't think it's like their heads or
anything like that i don't think killed
these people
necessarily
yes and in fact like it looks almost
like a temple maybe to these characters
whose characters exist in some way maybe
not in a way we can see with our eyes in
this universe right but like this is
kind of a temple to their spirits you
know what i thought too eric didn't
point out the um the the statue he kind
of says looks a lot like lady death
reminded me a lot of that very toothy
statue in the temple on wonder gore
mountain
uh oh thank you
kind of hooded figure yeah when i first
thought i thought red skull i was like
oh baby red skull gets to be in here
yeah
red skull again and then he popped up uh
an infinity war i was like my guys my
guy
he's gone i got my guy micah i just
don't know if i bl and maybe you guys
can speak more to this than i can i just
don't think those are the people that
judge whether or not jane foster gets
her powers right how would the watcher
we saw the watcher and what if that's
our first like mcu interaction with the
watcher uh and that is specifically like
r the watcher right so it's like how
who is he allowed to like give powers to
he doesn't he watches things he watches
things from afar um and i'm talking to
mcu i'm not talking about what's like
the comic books are telling us it's like
if you're gonna see the watcher in what
if and then see him here he has to be
the same person as he was and what if
yeah and have they talked about they
want to bring the i thought they
specifically said they wanted to bring
in jeffrey wright into live action at
some point or maybe
i know the the bigger story was like
animated characters can show up in
real world things hence captain carter
stuff like that uh but that just does
mean jeffrey wright could show up as the
watcher which would be so cool uh
that that's a good point though jessica
it is weird for like the living tribunal
would get involved here if all but the
one thing to consider is that like she
had the reality stone like inside of her
as part of her and a lot of people have
been theorizing that that's maybe like
what gives her cancer if they're gonna
go because they said they're gonna do
this cancer storyline if the reality
stone is like what made her sick maybe
this is like
the cosmos being like are bad that
shouldn't happen to you ma'am you're
you're not supposed to be a pawn on this
like cosmic chess board so we're going
to make good on that i don't know that's
easy i also
it's i'm i have this still on my other
monitor looking at it i think there's
more statues that were clearly not seen
and that they clearly don't want to show
us in the trailer yet um i think maybe
this is where she drops lands in and
then she walks down a hallway of like
other people that would be like oh
that's crazy maybe she winds up there
accidentally maybe some latent reality
stone energy
takes her there something like that it
this that this that room kind of makes
me think of like the tva where it's like
everything turned out to be fine
it's like this the bigger lie
uh maybe this is like kevin feige's
office and she walks into kevin feige's
office it's like i've made it all up
it's all made up
i can do whatever i want
i can do whatever yeah well we also put
a tremendous take uh
loves a good statue easter egg right we
got that beta ray bill giant head
uh in ragnarok um who knows maybe these
will have a huge pot implication maybe
these are just fun little easter eggs
there's a couple super chats i want to
call out first off owen john saying uh i
just saw on thor's back when his cloak
is blown off he's got those big back
tattoos including the loki horn helmet
yes that's something that we go into a
lot of detail in in the breakdown coming
out on the channel very shortly if it's
not already out uh good good eye there
owen um also uh i think john ayton
uh pointing out the helmet thor is
wearing is straight from the thor war
story line in the car oh
okay i gotta know good reference uh and
then td jones asking when will the break
room be back in the break when our
internet is back that's right
issues at the office td jones hopefully
we're fingers crossed for thursday
thursday we will be back which is ironic
thor's
day
well i just got chills you guys got
jealous i did see
oh i just did i did see some people in
the chat talking about some of those um
you know a couple of those shots that
look like they're framed for more
characters than are in them and maybe
people have been painted out some people
are speculating
beta ray bill some people are saying
maybe hercules teams up with these folks
is there anyone that you guys think
would be a great you know sort of plus
one for this movie that could kind of go
on the rest of this journey after we
sort of say goodbye to the guardians you
know dude i'm ride or die hercules i'm a
ryder dog jessica's
i want hercules so even if it's at like
the post-credits scene you know like
even if it's just like he comes out of
the rubble and he's like am i the only
one left and it's hercules like oh god
that'd be sick
so hercules for me
i mean i would like to see you know
somehow or like i would like to see an
expansion of the sim by symbiotes uh in
the mcu that's what i'm really hoping
comes from this more than anything
i still think they're waiting on that
name
they can't it sucks it's like that you
have to we have to wait we have to wait
we have to wait
yeah i'm i don't want to wait i'm gonna
throw out i'm gonna throw out a quick
wild card kind of tangentially related
to this but like richard ryder nova
um
this before supposedly that's a story
that kevin feige really wants to take or
really wants to tell um we know the
guardians are going to be in this and
they're making a nova story so
i was saying that to the rough riders
anthem but dmx i hope everyone knows
that that would be our late 90s uh power
ballad uh episode of this yeah that's
that's tomorrow
we did do a we did do a poll earlier
asking that the chat thought we would
see null in the mcu uh and the symbiotes
and stuff and 65 said yes so chad you
know you're making it happen you're
putting speaking truth to power that's
betting the over it's always gonna be
more fun to assume that something will
happen then it will never happen you
wanna bet that's always better
just to be definitive who had the best
power ballad
a landslide jessica coming in at 72
percent of them wow
those are big followed distantly by
tommy 11 brandon at 10. and you know
what this is four and a half more more
points than i thought i'd get five
percent for me
all right i mean you gotta you got a lot
of love in the chat zach uh
yeah dominique thompson was asking uh
was pointing out you changed topics like
a boss
uh and they want to start calling these
segways zagways
i think oh good i actually invested a
lot of money into zag ways in the uh
mid-odds
creator of zagways died on his way
what does that say about me
speaking of what it says about me and
dying that's the end of the episode
folks um
right there exactly
we appreciate you all joining us oh and
tune in tomorrow
last night or tonight i'm sorry
three-quarters of us including philip
and off-screen producer john some other
folks are going to see an early
screening of top gun maverick we will
talk about it tomorrow we're seeing an
imax tonight in burbank um and we're
gonna um feel the need for speed
throughout the rest of the week probably
dropping in some thoughts and some some
big hits look look for uh some photos on
social media probably but we thank you
for watching today we thank all the
folks in the chat all those cool super
chatters travis furman martine
elijah bowser keegan tv coming at us
from canada i believe alejandro
rodriguez our friend chrissy had some
great uh thor knowledge we did not get
to thank you as always chrissy um tune
in tomorrow the rest of the week
thursday we will be sans our good friend
tommy bechtel but we will be back in the
break room studio
uh let's all go re-watch that that
trailer and re-watch the new rockstars
breakdown have a great day everybody
[Music]
true
[Music]
it's true
[Music]
you